oh is that oh oh
no no
no i hope this isn't the whole episode
oh my god
somehow this is not gross compared to
the rest of the episode yeah i know
that's a photo it's a photocopy
high rise looks like you got better the
kinkos at least
we do have sex i
this is me every time i'm hanging out
with my friends i do have sex i promise
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season five episode four
seriously just spent an entire episode
explaining that there's no shame in the
game boys
as if the rick and morty fan base needed
any encouragement
uh but were we stuck
in this gross episode because rick lost
his portal gun
earlier this season well we say this
every week but tommy i think it's really
needed right now
what what this
is rick splained our rick and morty
after show where we go
one week exploring the existential
parallels between a teen romance and
environmentalism
just to see our thoughtfulness blow up
in our faces with
an episode about sperm monsters and
incest babies
i'm eric voss my easter egg breakdown of
all the details you
uh might have missed because you were so
grossed out that
breakdown's coming tomorrow but here i'm
with a very very responsible chud father
oh
tommy bechtola i was never hello eric
you work so hard and i don't envy the
fact that you
have to do an easter egg breakdown video
of this oh my god i will do every one
i am committed i will see this through
oh my god you poor poor poor deer
frame great to be here as always anyway
you know me i love rick and morty
if you don't love rick and morty and
it's come you don't get to love rick and
morty
and it's uh i i don't know
pick your favorite rick and morty
episode and insert it here you don't get
to enjoy mr nimbus if you don't get to
enjoy
you can't enjoy uh morty's giant
uh mutated monster sperm i want to
talk later in this episode about like
where fans draw the line and why they
draw
the line there because i do think a line
was crossed for sure
yeah i think we could all agree that
this was not a rick and morty episode
that we would recommend to people who've
never seen an episode
before you don't want to start with this
one um
yeah i mean you know i think about like
so my mom was an elementary school
teacher and i don't know how interesting
this is so editors cut this out if this
isn't
fascinating but uh my mom was an
elementary school
uh teacher and one of the custodians at
her school was a rick and morty
super fan so he would always try and get
my mom
a kindergarten teacher to watch rick and
morty and i can't imagine
if this had been the week that she had
finally been like
you know what no i'm gonna check this
show out
like on so many levels because i've also
when she told me
that that like you know that this has
been recommended i'm like oh you might
like it
it's really smart but like you know
i don't know this i don't think this one
was made for for moms or grandmoms
or dads or granddads or anyone i don't
think this was made for me
maybe a very specific subset of uh
pornhub users
but um i think every season it seems has
uh a real gross out episode like this
like season three had that fruity land
episode that i recently rewatched uh
because the writer of it
wrote that amazing recent episode of
loki
um but it was kind of gross some of the
subject matter season four had the [ __ ]
dragons
oh dragons yeah pretty gross yeah um
but neither of those compared to this
one this was
pretty messed up and i kept wishing rick
would have pulled out his portal gun to
escape this gross reality but then i
realized
he has not used it once this season
right and i think
you know we can figure out why but first
tommy let's just like break down
what happened this episode okay and
uh like any good blue man group concert
i do recommend wearing
some sort of poncho for this uh
description
because you might get some things on you
you don't want
uh morty mounts a horse even extractor
which is a sentence i prayed i would
never say
uh in beth's clinic rick tries to use
the material to create a bio weapon to
fight the chud horse
people but morty's genetic which was
what uh
cannibalistic horses under some well in
the movie it's cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers yeah but they just
made it horse
instead of human which uh but morty's
genetic material costs it creates
giant sperm monsters out of shame morty
refuses to own up to that fact
the president that recruits them on a
mission to lure the monsters to the
grand canyon
and nuke them perfect i actually think
one of the more genius plans uh
president of the united states has ever
had
but the monsters fight back and kill
their team of marines
marty befriends a young monster and
names him sticky because
of course why would it not be the
grossest thing i mean i guess
moist would be the only horse name yeah
oh
god the sperm queen plans to use the
machine
and and morty because the machine
doesn't work without morty
to make an army meanwhile the president
uses one of summer's eggs which is when
the episode
really lost me on the vegas strip to
lower the sperm
the chud horse people kidnapped reportee
but have
rick having made it with the princess
allows him to form an alliance with the
chad horses
to fight back against the sperm monsters
so obviously
again i'm saying a lot of things that
only rick and morty
would cause me to say out loud sticky
then and pregnant
summer's egg and the embryo is sent to
space
where in the post credit scene the giant
incest
baby kills an astronaut and
oh oh i'm sorry
tommy i'm sorry you had to read that
because do you just like putting it
in simple prescription terms
just makes the episodes i just i
i'm squirming not squirming sounds like
even gross to say
yeah everything just sounds gross now in
this context
but i am determined i'm determined to
find some
not necessarily deeper meaning because i
think it was clear but just to
help us all process what just happened
so we can move on
but before we talk more about this if
you want to help us make more great
content new rockstars like we explained
one of the best ways you can support us
is to check out our merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we got some brand new black widow
inspired designs in the shop including
our latest obsession the red deep
design and some fun russian nesting doll
designs uh
and of course we have our low-key
designs loki out of time
uh we have a new um gator loki polo
yeah there's some great stuff that you
can go get at new yorkstarsmerch.com and
it supports this channel but
what's our uh first question here tommy
that we should really talk about where
is rick's portal gun
and why hasn't he used it this season
yeah we kind of wish he had it this
episode right
yeah because i found it interesting so
far this seems like the first season in
which rick has not used his portal gun
once
in the first four episodes like and 501
is when he lost it he used a different
kind of portal at first to open that
narnia pocket reality but then he lost
the portal gun in there
and then 502 we interestingly explored
the infinite rick decoys within one
reality but not
across multiple realities 503 rick
embraced apocalypses on different
planets
uh and that one side into the portal gun
was right when rick was facing these
cyberpunk birds of the narnia reality
and then all of his implants got sucked
away but along with them was his portal
gun
and he has not used it since so he might
have lost it and rick might be stuck
in this gross reality and that might
explain some of the really weird stuff
we've seen from his fixation on
decoys his heightened nihilism and now
in this episode when that chad princess
uh
ponyta reveals that he fathered her
child he admits
i have a substance abuse problem yeah
which actually that was one of the
really funny lines this episode yes
and this isn't the first time the show
has acknowledged a lack of a portal gun
dilemma remember 301 that's when rick
was
imprisoned by the federation and morty
needed another portal gun so he dug up
rick's corpse in the backyard
like you know from when they had to bury
their corpses there for after
rick potion number nine um so that has
been the one he's been using
um and that one's now gone as well
um now just a quick acknowledgement
at some point dan hartman has said not
every episode takes place in the same
continuity that
rick and morty's just kind of a chaotic
show we might be seeing a different
universe each time we see an episode but
there has been enough uh animation
evidence
to show that there is some continuity on
this series
so like when you see um anytime you see
the graves in the backyard you know this
is in the post
rick potion number nine universe right
um when
uh characters get called back like clone
beth or bird person or tammy or evil
morty
that implies some continuity on the
series
and that like tells us that this wasn't
just like a bottle episode that was
unaffected by everything else that came
before or after
it uh and i think right now we are
seeing same continuity
um across these four episodes just by
him not having the portal gun now
we could be wrong of course like maybe
next episode um
they could just show that this was never
the case ricky uses portal gun
or like some alternate reality rick
could show up and the rick could steal
his portal gun
uh but i just think whatever is the case
for these four episodes it's just
interesting how the writers have given
themselves this challenge to stick rick
and morty in situations
that cannot be solved by rick just
portalling away from the universe and
starting over
and i kind of think a bit of continuity
could be a good thing if it challenges
the writers to give themselves rules
that they got to play by
now in this case seems like the episode
did not have much discipline
to it at all um but tommy i want to ask
you do you think rick and morty is a
better show when there is some
continuity that it holds itself to
or is it just more fun when it's like
interdimensional cable
it's just truly randomized uh and
chaotic
well i think it's a kind of two separate
things to me
like a better show and more fun i think
i liken it to like the simpsons
i watched the first episode of the
simpsons
as a kid and that is like you know like
in real time
like you know i was six years old when
the first episode aired or something
like that
so i remember my parents sitting us down
and we and simpson's being must see tv
but i think
the reason over time that i you know a
lot of people my age kind of let the
simpsons go
and like they come back to it every now
and then but they're not like religious
simpsons watches
is that there is like little bits of
continuity and there are little things
that become
canon in the world but it kind of resets
every decade to
be that decade like no one ages and not
that people are aging on rick and morty
but i think when you have no linear
story continuity i mean some characters
in the simpsons die and stay dead
and you know some characters you know
come out of the closet and stay
you know part of the lgbt community plus
sort of you know
i just think it's hard to latch on to a
show with any sort of permanent like
to really give a [ __ ] about it unless
there's genuine continuity in it because
otherwise it's
just kind of uh not it's just
anarchy you know it's like it doesn't
really matter not this
nothing matters and i know this is a
cartoon but it's a fun
cartoon that's really smart and really
deep and emotionally rich so it's like
yeah i want continuity in it because i
want to care about the characters and
not just be like oh well
whatever if you know if beth gets sawed
in half by a monster sperm it doesn't
matter because she'll be back next week
you know fit as a fiddle so i guess for
me my cranky old man sorry
rant is that i want continuity yeah you
know i think um
shows do still have to strike that
balance
of evolving with their audience's tastes
a little bit uh and like i think
this episode seems like the writer
saying well
we still want to be able to do this kind
of humor and i would say they do
and they still have every episode this
season at least has had some jokes in it
where i was like whoa
okay right this is a swim i guess this
the sensor rules are different when it's
not like
network prime time sunday night uh they
can do
when it's like 11 p.m eastern time you
can kind of go a little
go a little extreme um but like uh one
thing that rick and morty
tends to do really well is either like
uh smart concepts in a really dumb way
or dumb concepts in a really smart way
like you can do really gross things but
it has to like
it can't just go down that uh
down that rabbit hole of just getting
grosser and grosser it has to kind of
like critique them
you know and i keep waiting this episode
for that critique to happen
yeah uh or or for like they were clearly
aware of how gross this was yeah but
like
the story never course corrected for
that
they just stayed in it yeah and i think
that's that's where a lot of people are
left they're like
all right well there's always next week
yeah
for sure for sure i mean there are still
lots of really funny
funny parts of this episode is just
you're right they never
usually there becomes a level of
self-awareness of like wow
even for this show this has become
disgusting beyond
like what we're used to and it just
never happened they were like nope
we're gonna we're gonna inseminate this
this egg
that these are brother and sister
i have to ask this is not the first time
on rick and morty that they've kind of
joked about incest as being a kink and
we do not kink shame here
right like whatever you're into no
judgment there
yeah but uh you know within the laws of
the legal
system within like right exactly and
like moral and ethical
things right um the show
seems to be i don't think they have like
these weird fetishes that they're trying
to indoctrinate us with but i think they
are trying to like outsmart the viewing
audience yeah because and i'm not saying
there's anything wrong with this i'm not
saying
i'm into this but there are statistics
to show when you go on like pornhub and
stuff like that
yeah incest is a weirdly not popular
category but like more popular than you
think like
people are into it and i think that
makes the writers
laugh i think they find that really
funny yeah and when you look at shows
like game of thrones how it normalizes
incest
yeah in a really gross way you know like
yeah not just jamie
and cersei but by the end john and danny
like the fact that people were shipping
them and the show did not seem to be
saying anything was wrong with their
romance
like they're very closely related to
each other
yeah so i think that's like this is the
writers of the show being like
some of you are into this so let's make
fun of that
but i think for everyone reacting no
one's going to admit to being into that
everyone is either going to be
legitimately grossed out or pretend to
be grossed out
so i don't know anybody's gonna be like
yes finally finally an episode for me
so i don't know that's my defense of
like i'm just trying to imagine what's
going on in the writers room when
episodes like this happen like
someone is like laughing about this uh
and and they must see some kind of humor
there and i
i think like once you do get too far
down to like the hat on the hat
like just joking things and you've joked
about every possible thing that your
all your dry erase sports are full kind
of sometimes a gross idea like that wins
out and
just cracks up the room in a way that
like it might not crack up everyone else
well eric you know from
from sketch comedy and that we you know
we've both done sketch comedy before
it's like
there are plenty of premises that you
come up with with your friends and your
sketch
teammates that you are dying in the
writer's meeting
and like this is gonna kill this is so
funny and then you write it and you do
it
and the audience does not latch on to it
at all it's too
gross or too esoteric or too whatever
it's like you can when you're in
something as
insulated as i assume you know a
writer's room on a show like rick and
morty is it's like
yeah they probably laughed about it for
like five days together and we're like
this is gonna be
so great everybody's gonna love this and
you know what
we're just two people made in you know
there has been a pretty strong reaction
to it online but like
there might be a lot of people that like
loved this episode i think so
i think yeah i just think reactions are
are more mixed than usual
and i think they probably knew that this
is going to be a divisive episode too
it's kind of like you know because tommy
and i performed at um
io improv olympics los angeles theater
together um and that has like a certain
at least for a period had a certain
prestige like you didn't feel like you
could just like
put up any kind of experimental nonsense
that you wanted on that stage
because like you had to audition for
your spot you had to earn it and you got
other people to get a spot yeah
phrasing but the uh there are other
stages in la that are more experimental
and like over a certain time uh at least
sketch night at io did start to get more
experimental where it's like no one
really important is going to be in the
audience here other than the other team
who performed that night
so like i'm just going to put it up
whatever and then you'd get in these
debates with your teammates where
someone on the scene was like we can't
do that sketch it's disgusting or it's
offensive
and then you'd be like it's not
offensive whatever
and they're like well if the audience
doesn't laugh on it i don't care because
i'm an artist
and you start and i wonder if like
there's a bit of that i think the rick
and morty writers are all professionals
they're getting paid you know i think
they hold themselves to a very high
standard
but like when you have like 70 episodes
approved after season three or whatever
it was
you know i wonder if they're like well
we gotta we got to do an episode about
something
so this works uh but but then again it's
also really early yeah
or or they just wanted to do a dumb [ __ ]
joke
you know yeah i'm not gonna criticize
that much i
have to say like it's it's uh it's
there's no way of knowing
really i i just oh and it's just it just
was such a weird
episode after the first three that we've
gotten it was such a it was such a
i mean this show has a tendency to do
that to subvert expectations but
man it was just like well i was like i
wonder what crazy
you know thing i would have never
thought of uh we're going to see
this week and boy is that a be careful
what you wish for
uh statement wished like why did my
monkey paw close one finger after that
i want something i've never thought of
on rick and morty
i agree yeah uh all right so let's thank
some people who helped us make this
episode there are only two
fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss in our friends that
keeps offer both more than 50 million
men in the u.s suffer from male pattern
baldness and if you're one of those
keeps can help thank you to keeps for
sponsoring this episode keeps offers a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months
you don't even have to leave your home
the treatments start at just ten dollars
per month and keeps offers generic
versions of those fda approved
medications which ship in discrete
packaging
keeps has a proven track record of
performance and they have more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key with hair
loss
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you should act fast
and get on this now
and if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com rick's ricksplain to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com rick's plane to
get your first month for free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash
explain oh and fitting for this episode
uh thanks to bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode
our friends at blue chu have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cast
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package you sign up
at bluechew.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength
and if you hate swallowing pills good
news blue chew is chewable just like it
says in the name so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code ricksplained at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code
ricksplain to receive your first month
for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the show
and the show is also sponsored by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
we've all been there at some point
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own
licensed professional therapist start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help it
is professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available for clients
worldwide
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room or look for
parking
because betterhelp makes it easy and
free to change counselors if you need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit betterhelp.com
ricksplain that's better h-e-l-p and
join the over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states it's a
special offer for explained audience you
get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
explained
all right back to this episode so tommy
i want to ask you do you think
um in in fans eyes watching this who
might have been uncomfortable with the
subject matter do you think a contextual
switch
um like a switcheroo some kind of twist
might have saved the episode in some of
their eyes like how we saw in the bad of
an episode of the story train episode at
some point rick reveals that
all this stuff was like an extreme
lesson that he's teaching morty
or do you think that's the moment giant
sperm started attacking the world
some people were just done yeah i i
don't know because i think that
to abandon that
would have kind of just
even been even more what was the point
of all that you know what i mean like i
i hate to say like they had to see it
through to completion
but uh it was like i don't know that
they're
like what would the lesson have been the
only thing i could think of is that like
there could have been a reveal that
every single you know prominent male
character on the show had been using
that horse
machine so there was like there was no
clear
who the father was and like it would end
up in like a maury povich where it's
like
it's like jerry rick and morty are all
potentially you know the father but i
yeah
i don't i don't know that that like that
that
that that that could have worked for
this i don't i i don't see it i
i wish i was creative enough but if i
was i'd probably you know have a writing
job
[Laughter]
my answer is i'm not smart enough to
answer that question
yeah i i think like kind of once there's
some subjects once you start there
you gotta stay in it you know and it's
kind of hard no matter what
everything you do in it is gonna feel
tainted by it no matter how smart you
try to make it so maybe that's why they
just felt like then let's just
do the version of this we want you know
i'm not
you can't put the jizz back you know
what i mean like it's happening the spur
the sperm is out and it's like you know
you can't be like yeah this was all an
elaborate
ruse to teach you to not mess with my
whatever
my horse yeah but i think that's the
challenge they're like
can we do a version of a stupid you know
ejaculation joke
and and try to get as good of an episode
as we're
normally able to get and i respect i
respect that challenge at least you know
absolutely i mean i guess they could
have maybe turned it more into a
commentary of
the slightly the age-old like
culturally male thing of volunteering
because there's something sexual that
you want like whether it's like the hot
girl who also volunteers or
like you know like volunteering to
appear to be a better person
but in the end you're just using the
horse sex machine
so yeah i guess there could have been
more commentary on that but that might
be a little too sad
yeah i think they did try to provide
that commentary in the b plot with
summer
and beth like just they weren't being
listened to the scientists like he
peeded summer
uh and took her idea i just wish that it
didn't have to be summer's egg
you know like that just that was a step
too far i think for me
like i honestly was okay with a come
joke of the episode
uh it was once i reached there i'm like
well then i cannot defend this
yeah yeah yeah well speaking of
you know these um uh these this genetic
material
this giant incest baby uh do we think
this villain could return or are we done
with it like
this could you imagine the vindicators
and planet tina taking this thing down
and if not i just want to know how could
this thing breathe in space
i thought the same thing i'm like what
is
i'm sure there'll be an explanation but
oh my god i
i don't want it to return i i'm sorry i
don't i just don't mean either
there's a lot of really i i i don't mean
to be too woke or sensitive but there's
a lot of real
genuine victims of incest that like this
is just like
i mean a horrific giant comedic
you know kind of you too and i don't
think that they did that on purpose
obviously when you're making comedy the
chat you have a chance to offend
everyone as we know so
okay you got it in the post-credits
scene can this just never come back
in my i wish as a fan just speaking
purely
genuinely as a fan i would like it to
never come back
yeah i'd sooner see the the giant uh
you know homeless corpse of uh from the
anatomy park episode floating around in
space i do like this idea of just like
it's space's problem now and just
blasting stuff off to space
and then that stuff just being in the
background of stuff orbiting around
crashing into planets and stuff i think
it's funny as a world building concept
for sure
um but we're on the same page uh but
next question what'd you make of this
episode's references to the marvel films
like morty and beth are seeing
what beth called a shitty marvel movie
and then rick brings up iron man robert
downey jr's past
in the 90s that guy was sleeping in
bookings
i did like that a lot yeah i uh
i thought uh you know i think it's just
they're all they're they're
the writers screwing with each other a
lot of the old writers have gone on to
work for marvel properties current
writers
on the show jeff loveness is writing
ant-man three so it's like
you know i think it's maybe just uh like
just like a fun nod to each other
and and i it's a great mom joke to be
like i don't get this world
right yeah i think i love it as a line
coming from
beth like morty is still into seeing it
like he's still starting to see it
like that just says something like morty
is a pretty sophisticated you know
thinker like but they still give these
things to make him a kid and the fact
that he still just really wants to watch
it and beth's just being like
no i it's not for me i don't understand
why you're so crazy about it
right right but i i do love any time
uh rick and morty references the mcu or
the marvel world because it is like
one piece of pop culture that is more
popular than rick and morty
rick and morty's insanely popular but
like they'll
never be as popular as the mcu and the
fact that all their writers keep going
to write mcu projects i think it's gotta
just be like
all right but we're you're just writing
you're getting your gig to write a
marvel thing is that as challenging as
writing one of our
our sophisticated playing without
our rules of time and physics but and
then having a jizz episode
yeah and then having a culminate in
semen but uh i think also yeah i think
you know marvel is smart to hire these
writers because
like you know they the the thing about
rick and morty that you know we maybe
didn't get in this episode is like it
can be disgusting and it can also break
your heart in the same episode so it's
right
to have that and it can be smart and fun
it can be all of these things
get you a cartoon show that can do both
or all six
they're all all these things and i think
you know that that's what makes those
writers such desirable hires once
they're not working for the show anymore
it's like
to have that skill set is really
powerful so
right they're they're usu they're very
uh they got a lot of skills they have
a lot of discipline and uh just talking
with people like
uh like you are friends with a lot of
these writers we've met people like um
like ryan ridley um and just to talk
shop with them for a bit they all kind
of understand like well
i've given notes on scripts and
screenplays before and like
a lot of the scripts out there don't
have they'll call it like
a curve or a bend to it like it needs to
at some point
the character needs to achieve their
goals and those goals need to be proven
flawed in a way so then the character
truly grows and changes
and like ninety percent of the movies we
watch do not have
true character growth uh or they truly
do not go on a journey
they just travel places and they do
things and they blow stuff up
but they do not we don't learn anything
about them or about human nature
and you know not every rick and morty
episode hits this but the majority of
them do
like surprisingly a show that seems to
resist change
within the course of an episode you do
see character change
um and sometimes characters are punished
for changing but that's why i love
continuity
just a bit of continuity on rick and
morty is this season
you have seen morty and rick
not be and not have the same
relationship that they've had in
previous seasons and i think there has
been
some character growth by morty he's
still a kid he's still gross
but he does still have uh he has some
somewhat more adult uh thoughts and
feelings
as this is a long coming-of-age story
for morty not this episode though
well i guess you could say shame is a
universal was gonna say that
this one was definitely a coming of age
story but now
we will leave it there
[Laughter]
mom go watch this one we'll leave it
there for this episode explained my
easter egg breakdown of
all the little gross details you missed
in this episode we'll come out tomorrow
tommy and i will be back next week to
react episode five be sure to follow
tommy at tommy beck told follow me at ea
voss follow new rock star subscribe to
rick's blade wherever you get your
podcast thank you for watching
we'll close with our favorite moment of
the episode rico is the father of my
child
i have an heir i have a substance abuse
problem
[Music]
you